about 13 reasons why obviously that
first season really really took off and
season two is just around the corner I
know it's shrouded in secrecy but what
we do know is that you this next batch
of episodes will focus on serial sexual
abuse right yeah so how does the show
tackle that issue I mean I feel like it
tackles it in a lot of ways and not only
that but it's so many other issues
that's just around that sexual assault
but I think what's more important is
that you see all sides of the spectrum
from different characters because like
he says when it comes to someone being
sexually abused there's so many people
involved and so many people who get
affected by it so I think a way that's
smart that they're handling it is
showing like other people's and their
point of views and how they're being
corrupted and how it kind of interferes
with their lifestyle because I want the
world to not it's not so many Hanna
Baker's there's Marcus's there's
Sheree's there's teachers and you know
so it's it's good that they're showing
other sides of the stories as well I was
gonna say they really give each of you
guys so much to work with and not just
as actors but you also get to send such
so many different kinds of messages to
so many different people I met I bet
that feels for you as an actress like
the cherry on top of a sundae right
because you have the job opportunity but
now you have a responsibility it's
awesome yeah for sure and you know one
thing for me I've been doing this for a
long time so I I always make sure I take
on roles that that serves my purpose of
what I want my career to serve and so I
don't just take anything and so it has
to be something that's kind of I feel
will benefit the world in a way and
young adolescents and so like you say to
be able to do something I love and have
a responsibility and get that across
that's a blessing it's like you're
getting your job done but also serving
things for a higher purpose and reality
of life such heavy subject matter but
you look like you're having fun too much
have you guys bonded over this
experience yeah I think first season was
so fun we went out of high you know went
out to dinners
second season it was a little different
because we had more of a fan base and so
especially out in San Francisco like
it's so small you go to one little area
somebody takes a picture in this
literally crowds coming and we're like
we're gonna go yeah yeah it's a little
hectic sometimes so I feel like season
two was more secluded and then we were
more so in houses and our hotels and
stuff like that but it was still really
fun you guys had each other together
it was super dope um what's one word you
would use to describe season two of
thirteen reasons why Oh plot twist okay
so you guys might be teeing it up for
another season huh I'm just putting on
the universe
because they're trying to manifest back
you know something tell y'all gonna get
it um so yeah you mentioned gabrielle
was a fan of 13 reasons why we should
try to get any scoop out of you you know
something yes you do I haven't even read
this because they give it to us yeah I
was shooting thirteen and so they give
us the scripts as we go and is
constantly changing so like we're at our
table reason we're like oh my god it's
like we're figuring it figuring it out
as we go and we're filming I was
exciting it is exciting I can't wait to
watch that I'm a binge it yes thank you
that flex for putting all those episodes
up at one side I'm not trying to waste
any time